[Music]
with foam courage the radio show we're
outside the studio with Todd Hickey
filmmaker behind takedowns and falls an
amazing wrestling documentary and also
part of resilient fix and we were just
chatting with Todd about what he'd like
to do for his next documentary that he
has sort of in his mental pipeline here
and he talked about how you want to
maybe not be so emotionally invested in
your quote subjects and maybe almost
have people who were seen as villains
right yeah absolutely I like we talked
about on the show a little bit I think
that one of one of the more difficult
things was being so invested personally
becoming personally invested in the
characters in the film we're really
rooted for them we really cared about
them and ultimately we were concerned
about their portrayal you know that it
was an honest portrayal that didn't hurt
anyone's feelings and everyone felt like
they were treated honestly and fairly
you know and that you know was a
considerable amount of anxiety
I guess generated from from that concern
editing the film and I've decided I'd
like to go in the other direction with
my next film and make it about people
that I would going into it maybe it's
dangerous but consider villains as
opposed to heroes and and and I think
there's a lot of them out there
and there's a lot of you know room for
for us to examine some things that are
going wrong I think take down some falls
we our purpose was to examine some
things that were right like you're some
people that are doing things in a way
that works that's healthy for them in
some regard and and I want to examine
that that got natural gas industry and
media's influence on public policy and
it's really big and Pennsylvania right
we're takedowns and falls was also made
and you know I want to examine the
meters influence on how the laws are
being written and why they're why people
are voting the way they are which seems
to be in their own demise you know
because by all accounts fracking is
pretty dangerous it's pretty poisonous
it's poisoning groundwater and the
couple of films that have come out that
exposed that have been attacked by big
lobbying firms that are hired by the
natural gas industry and I think that
you know there's media being made and
now that media is being attacked by
media and then and and now we would
examine that and how that actually like
plays out in and how people vote and end
up voting and what people end up seeing
and how they're convinced that this is
good for them or bad for them as a
community you know and people as
communities are voting like for it so so
what is it that's convincing them that
this thing that is poisoning them is
actually good for them you know I mean
that's not you know what I mean that
it's it's quite a difficult paradigm
that they're stuck in people come to buy
your mineral rights from you they tell
you it's okay but then science proves
that it's probably poisoning your
groundwater you know what what other
than the money convinced you and as a as
a homeowner as a landowner that this was
something that is in your best interests
you know and there's a ton of money
behind you know the pro gas industry
because it's all there's a ton of money
going to it and there's a ton of money
invested in lobbying for it but you know
there's not too much like consumer
protection out there concerning it not
too many people that are able to afford
to get all the information they need to
make a better decision so we would like
to examine that information channel and
and and how it affects how people make
decisions about their own land about
their own rights and ultimately their
own health
that's fascinating yeah the one thing
I'm thinking do you fear a backlash
knowing that there is so much money
behind the industry what if you put out
something as I imagined it being amazing
and having great success and then be
very truthful do you do you envision and
do fear what type of backlash would
happen I'm sure there would be some
backlash if it was successful but I
don't fear it at all I think this is
information that has to be out there and
you know what what can they do to us
right it's like we're filmmakers like
ultimately what could they really do you
know like but I think in some cases the
backlash will drive its popularity you
know and sometimes that backfires
absolutely for large lobbying firms that
for example the film Gasland by Josh Fox
I know Josh was attacked that personally
it seems and his film was attacked that
as if it was providing misinformation
when the campaign against it was the
infamous information but they have a
farther reach a louder voice they can
buy hats on television you know so they
in some ways win those battles if we
don't keep fighting back if there's no
one that just keep like no come like no
you're not telling the truth we're
telling the truth you're lying but if
you know if the liars get to say it more
than ultimately they win I think you
know we see that over and over in
America right now with all kinds of
decisions that are being made by
Americans that seem to be in their own
disinterred you know and they're not
there I'm not best interests you know
going back to something you said about
takedowns and Falls I mean you were very
emotionally invested in the people in
the film so in keeping with not wanting
to hurt people
feelings and especially in this industry
where you can hurt someone's feelings
and not even realize it as we're all
sensitive we all have egos how did you
deal with that how did you work around
showing someone and not hurting their
feelings with it being so close to the
subject I think it was just this like
personal somewhere that felt like that's
manipulation you know like this like
you're manipulating that if you put
those together that's that's not honest
you know that's some manipulation by
juxtaposing two images you know I mean
that like anytime we felt we were
crossing the lie and then it then then
we decided not to do it you know but if
if it felt like it was the truth you
know and that we weren't manipulating it
then then we went forward with it and
some of those truths are difficult you
know for people to know about themselves
are here about themselves or for kids to
hear what other kids are saying about
them stuff like that you know like none
of those kids ever asked to be in the
film and you know I took the
responsibility of not like you know
destroying that character very seriously
you know I mean we all have character
flaws and it's so easy to make someone a
villain in a movie you know but is it
fair it's it the right thing to do just
for a dramatic license you know so we
took that very seriously and if we felt
like we were crossing the line then we
didn't do it you know some films demand
that even some documentaries demand that
but we didn't think that those kids
deserved it and and we didn't think like
the film demand it had it it has its own
dramatic arc this season provides that
the characters illnesses provide that
you know so to just sort of target
someone to make a point you know in an
easier fashion because that's all it
comes down to it's like do we make a
point in a difficult fashion that's
going to take more
work and more shots and maybe not have
the same punch or do we just cheat to
the point you know and we decided not to
not cheat the point you know and take
the long way and that's why he puts two
hours long
[Music]